alors bonjour tout le monde bonjour la
planète bons joueurs à montréal bonjour
le canada joue sur la planète
c'est beau bonjour la planète d'une
émission à la radio de rang rfi radio
france internationale samedi quelque
chose je pense que c'est le cas
il avait un peu copié sur la formule de
radio canada international qui est le
courrier mondial
j'ai une famille hérités d'une famille
entre les deux titres j'expliquerai pas
tout je vais aller au fond des choses
aujourd'hui
d'abord on recommence bonjour on est
trois on est très nombreux ici un studio
moins nombreux que d'habitude pour
célébrer le 375e anniversaire non pas de
radio canada international mais devant
rien ici autour de la table les hô chi
minh au le webmestre en chef de radio
canada
bonjour marie claude simard également va
falloir changer sa photo sur la photo
officielle parce qu'elle a bon c'est la
couleur de l'été vous avez besoin
d'avoir le vent dans les cheveux
c'est exactement vous avez une belle
chevelure que je pensais blanc du
finalement c'était blain et maintenant
c'est rendu guérite au tracé plus court
c'est plus foncé avec un petit peu
d'artifices là vous reconnaissez c'est
l'essentiel
et vous reconnaissez le siège vide qui
appliquée il tempête à cette côte est
mais normalement and arrive on devrait
s'y asseoir mais anne marie est très
occupé à la section autochtone de radio
canada international à l'espace
autochtone et puis elle m'a dit ce matin
stéphane bouthiaux libéré j'ai dit non
avec plaisir bien sûr
alors ce 75e 375e anniversaire
on va se tromper dans les dates parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'anniversaires a
concédé m cette année le 150e aussi du
canada oui le 75e 2
je magasine même quelque part à montréal
sur le 45e à moi le vrai j'ai lu je les
mets ont continué à fêter toute l'année
85e cette année également ça nous porte
bien a baissé mais blague à part c'est
pas nous les personnages importants de
l'histoire pour lancer cet anniversaire
le titre de l'émission ses 375 bonnes
raisons de célébrer le 375e anniversaire
on en mettra pas 375 sur la table on en
remet 5 ou 6 après ça vous compléter la
liste à vous d'écrire la suite de cette
aventure grâce à notre site web vous
allez voir voici une des histoires dont
on va débattre ensemble aujourd'hui vous
allez oust détails
cherchez plus d'informations au fello
que vous allez sur le site de la page
dans tout le canada
tout ce dont on parle à chaque émission
on le reflète dans cette page là en
détail
belmadi ben comme ali ben mailly c'est
un nom avec lequel vous devriez donc
j'ai pas de lumière qui s'allume ans non
non non non non non je le connais pas
vous êtes sur une voiture de sa mère
patate gelé
un pendu quelque part mais je me
rappelle pas bon marie-claude tessalit
désolé l'ambassadeur du 375e
anniversaire de montréal
originaire d'algérie qui arrive en sol
canadien
il y avait un petit concours d'il ya
deux ans trouvez l'ambassadeur de
montréal qui va refléter cette fête au
plan international qui va courir d'une
activité à l'autre bien le voici le
voilà voici la vidéo qui a permis de se
qualifier et à travers cette vidéo on
découvre ce jeune homme de 30 ans
quelques jours et puis aussi une partie
de la vie qui l'a amenée ici à montréal
c'est l'histoire de beaucoup de gens qui
s'y trouvent déjà ici alors que montréal
bien on va le voir il ya un très fort
pourcentage de citoyens qui sont nés de
l'étranger poteau de poids de l'étranger
mais à l'étranger
voici venu balise vidéo originale qu'il
a pu a permis de devenir notre
ambassadeur
[Musique]
rouler
bon
[Musique]
selinger sa mort
ben mahi à l'image de montréal
aujourd'hui
il ya trois cent soixante quinze ans
était également le visage de montréal
les nouveaux arrivants ils sont arrivés
par bateau enfin de la ville de québec
et puis d'abord de france et puis ils
sont débarqués ici à montréal on va
raconter une partie de l'histoire vers
la fin de l'émission
mais aujourd'hui on s'intéresse au
visage canton contemporain de montréal
qui célèbre son 375e anniversaire de
naissance jeu-questionnaire premier jeu
questionnaire vous êtes prêts oui on a
50 50
d'ailleurs une affaire de pourcentage je
vous demande je reviens petit peu sur la
notion évoqué avant la diffusion de la
vidéo de paiement
quel est le pourcentage de montréal est
qui sont nés à l'étranger ou dont les
parents sont nés à l'étranger on combine
les deux liquides un combiné avec les
parrains ou et non 60 à 160 personnes
moi oui 25 pour ça oui ça fait vous
allez pas souvent dans le métro non moi
non plus je n'y vais pas souvent mais je
je d'après les statistiques officielles
vous n'êtes pas loin de la réponse vous
allez pouvoir vous racheter aux
prochains jeux questionnaires caire
alors c'est gagné 56%
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première fois demain je sais
pas combien de temps 85 kg depuis depuis
depuis presque un an qu'on a cette
formule de vidéos on a commencé à quel
moment exactement
oui oui là-bas c'était l'année passée
moi je sais pas je me rappelle pas bien
adaptés il faudrait aller voir ses
besoin d'engranger de manger dans quinze
jours bon alors cette bravo pour
félicitations par marc angrand c'est
donc ce premier jeu questionnaire et
puis marie-claude vous n'allez pas vous
racheter et presque tout de suite
tous jouent pas pour gagner je joue pour
le plaisir le temps en temps c'est beau
gagner dans quelques instants deuxième
jeu questionnaire pour le moment le
visage multiculturel de montréal on va
aller sur le site de la presse du
quotidien la presse à montréal puisqu'il
y a quelques mois alors que montréal 375
qui était un comité organisation a
préparé les choses a lancé sur le
youtube une vidéo où on ne voyait que
des visages blancs pas beaucoup de
visages du métro sur cette vidéo grand
scandale une histoire qui avait raconté
de façon vraiment c'est un beau travail
du quotidien la presse et la ville à
enlever toute trace de cette vidéo aux
visages blancs de montréal ne reste plus
aucun écho sauf à la presse ou sur le
cdal le facebook de la presse donc
les voici voici voici la trace comme les
inspecteurs de police voici
voici l'histoire
bienvenue à montréal
déjà sacrés dont
je passe au toute ma vie c'est chez nous
s'il m'avait jamais
trois états
voilà il ya eu un problème technique du
côté de la presse ou de facebook a lancé
pas de notre faute mais c'est vous avez
quand même le début avec les visages là
alors qu'à montréal c'était un autre
montréal est montréal des années 60 1960
il ya une cinquantaine d'années avant
que cette grande ville s'ouvre
véritablement au courant international
notamment grâce à l'expo de 1967
alors vous êtes prêt pour le deuxième
jeu questionnaire oui oui l'occasion
pour certains d'entre vous de vous
racheter et pour d'autres additionnez
comme sur deux victoires alors on dit
souvent que montréal est une des grandes
villes de francophones dans le monde
elle est en combien deuxième position au
niveau de la francophonie auf excuse on
s'est d'abord paris c'est la première
d'alors en italie ça c'est sur la table
paris première ville francophone au
monde
montreal lé ou sur la liste des 10 plus
grandes villes mais sait pas sur quoi ça
ce palmarès c'est le nombre de personnes
qui le nombre de restaurants population
il faut alors la première 10-15 je sais
pas combien de villes en france mais
toutes les villes françaises qui sont
plus documenté et c'est vraiment bête la
danse dans ce cas dans ce palmarès
montréal
on chiffre à 4,2 millions de population
donc c'est le grand montréal au grand
regret donc c'est un peu cinquième
session 20e sur combien vous avez dit je
dirais
7e se tient oui c'est vrai on avait
coutume de dire nous dans nos reportages
arts du canada et en assurant que s'il
était la deuxième ville francophone en
importance dans le monde est là quand on
se met à vérifier les choses quelques
années plus tard les choses ont beaucoup
évolué et kinshasa république
démocratique du congo bien elle
surclasse maintenant paris première
ville fera qu'enfin 11 millions et demi
d'habitants
paris 10 millions huit cent cinquante
huit mille et deux jeux des deux abidjan
côte d'ivoire troisième en importance au
monde 4 millions 800 mille montréal
bon j'ai dit combien combien millions
tantôt 4.2 bon il ya ici les chiffres
c'est 4 millions
presque cent mille et on est en
quatrième position au cours d'un canon
point bas jallet 5e levée du siège à 10%
de la bonne réponse
cinquième c'est dakar sénégal 3 millions
et demi de personnes ont même beaucoup
de pays
en fait de ville
afrique et casablanca
je pense qu'elle arrive sixième
wahhabite juin 6e 7e 8e l'afrique est là
et puis yaoundé au cameroun
ouais mais c'est que c'est incroyable
c'est grave à paris c'est seulement
français puis au reste des villes que
vous avez nommés cia n'a plus fière
c'est le shearling bas kinshasa par
exemple quand on me dit que c'est la
première ville francophone au monde il
suffit de pas dans le métro de kinshasa
existait dans les autobus et les bus
vrai vous allez voir que les gens par
dans les dialectes il 50 2 60 ethnies
différentes avec des dialectes
différents
le français n'est que la langue qui qui
rassemble tout le monde peu comme si moi
même à montréal on s'entend que c'était
comme à paris mais quand même l'anglais
qui est très présent paponi sa lentille
de l'histoire de montréal ou le chinois
et puis ça sent bon acte et est ce qu'on
est prêt pour une autre vidéo
oui parce que j'ai un autre jeu
questionnaire quand même j'ai pensé à
tout et 11e avant la vidéo je vous donne
de suite une occasion pour acheter je ne
veux pas faire vous faire languir voici
je pense que là vous allez combien coûte
le 375e anniversaire de montréal c'était
dans les journaux à la une dans les
journaux à la une il ya environ trois
semaines
quand c'était quoi déjà beaucoup non
vous avez toutes les vitres arrières
beaucoup
mais met en route et le temps on sait
que c'était 40 millions les ponts à
l'arbre voilà combien ces 60 millions le
pompiste à 40 millions guerbigny c'est
bon c'est bon alors voilà
d'accord je pense que ça va par contre
là combien ça coûte
mais plusieurs centaines de millions
c'est tout d'abord presse dit vas-y à la
la la la voici la réponse sous forme
vidéo
ok c'est de radio canada une enquête
faite par une de leurs équipes
montréal célèbre mais le 375e et coûte
combien
on a calculé le 375e vous coûter un
milliard évidemment s'il n'y a pas de
dépassements de coûts oui un peu plus
d'un milliard de dollars ça c'est à peu
près trois fois le prix du nouvel
amphithéâtre de québec de ce milliard de
dollars ce qui organise les fêtes ont un
budget de 125 millions mais l'essentiel
des dépenses ce sont des infrastructures
comme la place pour klein ici dans le
vieux-montréal complètement refaite pour
12 millions d'autres exemples le quai où
on accueille les touristes qui
débarquent des bateaux croisières
revampé pour 78 millions
il ya aussi un ancien dépotoir
transformé en parc 26,6 millions en tout
il ya un peu plus de 40 projets dans le
bâtiment derrière ce sera la maison
internationale des arts de la
marionnette pour deux millions cinq cent
sur le milliard de dollars de dépenses
c'est la ville de montréal qui paient la
plus importante pas suivi du
gouvernement du québec et celui du
canada
il ya aussi d'autres sources de
financement comme des entreprises
privées
[Musique]
la plupart des legs vont perdurer dans
le temps comme l'illumination du pont
jacques cartier qui est prévu pour dix
ans vous voulez qu'on vérifie quelque
chose
écrivez nous
alors on applaudit marie-claude jusqu'à
la tête plusieurs centaines de milliers
ans quand même plus d'un milliard c'est
plusieurs centaines de millions vous
avez reçu plusieurs messages
d'encouragement sont révélés hier des
internautes qui m'encourage me disent
bravo marie claude la cheville persévère
et ben c'est joël honoré quam qui nous
dit bonsoir à tous toujours au rendez
vous depuis douala aux caméras puis est
malika mère barks nous irons pakistan
good programme alors eyadou à l'aise
qu'elle paraissait dans votre palmarès
des jeux fra d'achat oui je me suis
aperçu mais pas noté l'un à quai c'est
sur un sol d'air douala ça parlait
beaucoup de personnes qui parlent un
anglais là bas parce que quand on est si
ce cadre une série de lancers les deux
c'est l'autre pays au monde avec le
canada où il ya ces bilingue français
anglais
ça n'existe pas à penser le pays de tout
ça est un prénom c'est par exemple
l'australie aurait pu passer par une
vague de francophonie non non non donc
la dualité francophones anglophones ne
s'est pas beaucoup de nations qui la
vivent comme ça officiellement en tout
cas officiellement au niveau de la loi
est ce que je peux vous proposer un brin
d'histoire maintenant j'ose d'histoire
j'ose pas tourner ça sous forme de gie
question ce serait tourner le fer dans
la plaie mais aucun témoin ou si le jeu
je joue a avoué que mais des fois je
mets juste plutôt est compétent lorsque
j'ai des réponses mais moi je pense pas
pas mal exécuté notre affaire alors
jeanne mance jeanne mance
moi je me souviens d'avoir entendu
parler jones lorsque j'étais enfant
le parc jeanne mance très bonne on joue
francis tebboune ont déminé nom qui nous
accompagnent dans la vie et on prête pas
trop attention c'est pas trop ce que de
quoi il s'agit mais c'est non cette typo
nomi je pense que ces mots exacts pour
parler de la science des dunes de ce
qu'ils nomment ou des fans des noms
condamne nos rues et aux parcs et aux
endroits
bien aussi jamin scène en plein remplace
d'honneur elle devrait être la
cofondatrice de montréal et elle vient
tout juste d'être reconnu comme
cofondatrice de montréal au même titre
que maisonneuve ouais bah on a toujours
dit - 9 rue l'homme qui est venu avec
ses bateaux et ses hommes s'installer à
montréal au niveau des iroquois qui lui
faisait là le vous savez l'histoire est
assez machiste cette machine c'est ça le
problème est bien un espagnol un homme
ou chanson qui dit et si l'histoire
racontée pour ceux qui écrit fait passer
pour ce qu'ils gagnent cela veut dire
qu'il y en a une autre histoire
mais c'est vrai qu'avec jean mances il
ya une toute une histoire en arrière je
dis aussi qu'ils perdent en écrivent
leurs propres histoires teintées pas
toujours débout de la bonne histoire non
plus mais je sais pas si quand ceux-ci
ici le super voir l'argent pour publier
en histoire bon question vous posez au
fret devrait faire une émission spéciale
sur l'histoire j'y avais pensé avant
aujourd'hui
en dix ans et a beaucoup à dire sur les
histoires au canada et l'histoire on se
raconte aussi au québec dans les deux
sens du terme n'est ce pas figurer bon
mais ça ce sera pour une autre histoire
maintenant au sujet de jeanne mance oui
belle histoire que moi j'ai découvert en
étant obligé de répondre à une question
d'un auditeur d'une triste je pense dans
ce cas ci parce que les gens ne vous
interpelle en disant oui oui vous savez
tout pour vous le dire
alors que je vais faire de la recherche
et cette fois ci on avait fait une vidéo
on adore faire des vidéos ça prend
beaucoup de temps
mais le résultat était beaucoup plus
percutant voici ce que ça donne
au niveau de l'image et du son
l'histoire de jeanne mance cofondatrice
de la ville de montréal il ya trois cent
soixante quinze ans c'était au mois de
mai de quelle année 704 on écoute et
nous sommes
en conversation avec madame fernande
quentin qui se trouve à la grande digue
c'est tout nouveau brunswick et le nom
indique bien sûr l'endroit approximatif
le long de la côte canadienne la côte
est canadienne où elle se trouve en ce
moment là même quand un bon soir pour
toi alors grande digue est ce que vous
savez en quelle année on a appelé ça la
grande digue
pour faire très longtemps ça doit être
au début du 20e siècle
au début vous nous avez posé une
question sur l'histoire du canada il a
fallu remonter aux origines qu'il est
exactement votre question je suis fan à
connaître l'histoire de jeanne mance
infirmières laïque qui a laissé sans
payer la france pour venir colonisé j'ai
cru comprendre la nouvelle france serait
arrivé ici un fait 142 avec monsieur oui
alors maisonneuve
heymans de nom qui commence par m et si
vous retenez ça vous avez les débuts de
l'histoire de montréal tôt syfact 516
141 vous avez à ce moment-là 541 les
premiers navires qui quitte la france
pour aller créer une nouvelle ville
il y en avait déjà une qui existaient
qui s'appelait à québec québec fondée en
quelle année
kébé exactement bonne mémoire on vient
de célébrer le 400e
c'était la seule grosse ville j'en avais
une autre française autres villes
françaises dans votre coin en acadie
est-ce que c'est à dire ben ça se
termine par police à l'époque annapolis
voilà alors c'était 2 les deux villes si
vous voulez à ce moment-là française sur
la côte mais à l'intérieur des terres
n'y avait pas encore de ville c'est à
dire que québec se trouve à l'embouchure
du fleuve saint-laurent et si vous
pénétrer à l'intérieur des terres lien
une île qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui montréal et on a pensé à ce
moment là il y avait déjà des colons
français qui était venu au début du 16
cents 1 502 il était débarqué sur l'île
de montréal il s'était dit ce sera un
bel endroit pour kai est une ville
puisqu'elle se trouve au confluent de
quelques rivières dont il ya beaucoup de
circulation d'amérindiens qu'il pourrait
nous apporter des peaux d'animaux
on pourrait faire du commerce
l'important commerce qui serait
profitable à la france la couronne donc
mais on est plusieurs années et il faut
évidemment avoir des investisseurs c'est
un projet privé mais sanctionné par le
roi mais le roi dit je veux pas quand
même tout payer vous allez faire le tour
des nobles et voir qui veut contribuer
les jésuites notamment ont voulu
contribuer et on a envoyé donc une
expédition qui est arrivé à la ville de
québec en 741 on a passé l'hiver à
québec et en 142 on arrive à montréal où
se ce combat on va appeler sa ville
marie un la ville de marie et il fait
partie de l'équipe donc madame ans
jeanne mance et maisonneuve ce moment là
on est entouré par des amérindiens
desiro quoi nous allons impressionnant
oubliée dans les livres d'histoire des
jeunes québécois aujourd'hui les
iroquois font partie des premières
nations et on en dit du bien sauf qu'a
eu quelques tensions tension qui pouvait
amener les colons à perdre leur scalp et
c'est ce qu'a connu jeanne mance était
une des trois femmes seulement dans
cette folle équipée qui venait créer une
ville ville-marie lahoud où je vous
parle c'est pour ça qu'elle est passée à
l'histoire parce qu'elle est la demande
et de la bravoure et en plus de ça cette
femme là non seulement elle était elle
avait elle avait commencé physiquement
les têtes fait très forte elle était
aussi très bien connecté politiquement
elle est retournée en france une coupe
d'occasion en a fait partie de nos
missions pour retourner en france en
compagnie maisonneuve pour aller
chercher de l'argent dit sionnel pour
certains projets et vous savez ce que
jeanne mance a créé le tag est devant
rien
c'est l'hôtel je sais pas c'est pas un
hôtel c'est un hôpital n'est ce pas on
l'appelait la maison de même aux
allemands ce jusqu'au début jusqu'a fin
du de la vie de jeanne mance elle est
morte en 773 jusqu'à la fin on était
toujours en période de guerre ou deux il
y avait des accalmies des fois mais on a
toujours l a toujours connu la guerre
avec les iroquois ce n'est que trente
ans plus tard qu'il ya eu presque 30 ans
plus tard qu'on a signé une paix il ya
bien une histoire fameuse au sujet de
mme énorme maisonneuve qui a eu l'audace
monnaies il a eu connaissance qui avait
desiro quoi quitter rennais ou qui
rôdaient autour est tout seul il est
allé de l'autre côté de la palissade
avec un revolver il n'a tiré que
quelques coups de feu et tous les tous
ceux qui étaient restés à l'intérieur du
fort c'est à dire mais il va y passer il
voyait mais il est extrêmement courageux
un moment donné il ya un iroquois qui se
lance vers lui avec pour le pavec une
commune à personne
1 h pour le scalper haut et lire quoi
est lui tombé dans les bras et par un
tour je ne sais trop comment on s'est
tous les gens qui observaient la scène
dit ça y est il il est mort il a réussi
à maîtriser les roquois et à le tuer de
ces de ses propres brad avec cette force
était forcée lui le fondateur de la
ville de montréal et avec lui cette
jeanne mance 7 et on peut parler d'une
héroïne parce que c'est occuper de tous
les blessés de toutes les personnes qui
avaient besoin d'un décès souvent les
colons au départ c'était dur d'affronter
l'hiver et beaucoup d'admiration pour
jeanne mance parce que étant infirmière
et 7ème siècle
peut être c'est moi qui vous remercie
stéphane vous nous avez raconter une
belle histoire
je vais aller faire mes lectures alors
voilà c'est un de nos auditrices à la
grande digue au nouveau brunswick à
l'histoire d'un homme
fernand quand quelque chose qui n'était
pas écrit dans les lits l'histoire
le nom des femmes n'apparaît jamais dans
les histoires mais on s'est mis que les
femmes est elle aussi là c'est un cours
de biologie auquel on a droit est assez
bien c'est bien écouter et vous m'avez
dit tu as oublié quelque chose de lui
pendant que la vidéo rouler c'était la
question de la semaine en fait on n'a
battu chaque semaine en une question je
vais essayer de la retrouver qui était
quand même fort intéressant on n'a pas
eu des internautes qui ont répondu cette
semaine on en a plusieurs qui coûte ans
mais en a beaucoup qui coûte alors la
question était d'abord on disait
montréal invite le monde à célébrer en
ce moment sont 300 son 15e anniversaire
mais montréal peut-elle encore affirmé à
la face du monde qu'elle est une ville
de classe internationale alors pendant
qu'ils ont réfléchi à cette question les
eaux
on va montrer ce qui est plus
spectaculaire en ce moment au niveau de
la ville de montréal c'est le pont
champlain
non le pont jacques cartier qui a été
construit j'ai appris ça ce matin j'ai
vu des images l'époque en 1929 il ya
presque cent ans et moins de temps en
temps mais presque et c'est un ouvrage
tout à fait extraordinaire se trouvait
au pied du pont il ya environ un mois à
la recherche d'un stationnement pour
passer au dessus du banc mais jamais en
dessous points
puis j'ai regardé les dalles de béton
énorme la hauteur de sa c'est un pont
extraordinaire qui a ses problèmes
évidemment comme nous les grands
ouvrages ici à montréal depuis quelques
temps et nécessite un peu de
reconstruction mais c'est quand même
impressionnant pendant qu'on parle de
montréal international on voit les
images du feu d'artifice et j'y allais
le mien pour le moment il n'y avait pas
de feu d'artifice ce soir là mais il y
en aura pas non plus si je pense que
c'est à la fin fin toute fin oui il y en
a eu un
sujets semés en fait les buts s'était
montré où on a dépensé les 40 millions
et 1 milliard
ouais c'était vraiment l'exposition
d'une festival des lumières sur les
pompes
c'est vraiment étonnant c'est que
spectaculaire
puis ça a pris pas mal tant pis ça va
être pendant dix ans je pense sur les
ponts alors ces cas-là millions / d'ici
dix ans un avion à chaque fois l'année
c'est ça et c'est papa représentation
une représentation dure une demi heure à
peu près quelque chose comme ça que je
n'ai pas la donne est exact mais ça dure
papa d'un mois la durée est très très
courtes très brève et ça va être
représentée à l'affût 24 25 juin autour
de la fête nationale des québécois en
deuxième représentation exclusive alors
ça c'est là les bas la belle image nuit
mais derrière l'image quand on gratte
m'ont rien ce que c'est encore une ville
internationale de qik est inspirant qui
est un modèle pour les autres je pense
que oui mais moi je pense que dans
certains domaines mais dans beaucoup de
domaines non mais ça veut pas dire que
ça vaut le détour je crois que comme on
dit morial vous le détour vous venez ça
vaut la peine de venir nous voir mais de
vraiment se qualifier comme une grande
ville internationale
peut-être certains domaines comme par
exemple je pense à la musique parce
qu'on a vraiment d'abord un orchestre
symphonique extraordinaire mais on est
aussi plein de festivals tout ça mais si
on pense à l'histoire l'architecturé au
transport en commun
est-ce que ça se comporte vraiment à
beijing à paris m
une
quand je suis fait du tourisme moi
j'étais en europe 1 seule fois dans ma
vie
puis je prenne pas compte de 200
transports ça c'est que les choses qui
on vit à l'intérieur de la ville ouais
c'est ce qu'il considère met par exemple
en argentine quand on nous envoie dans
un endroit pour acheter de billets
montréal est toujours toujours affiché
il ya comme ces roms paris new york
montréal boston
il sait c'est une attraction touristique
c e ville
j'étais curieux de découvrir montréal
parce que c'est vrai on est la plus
grande ville francophone en amérique du
nord
déçu quand je fais cm
la passe pour venir habiter à montréal
je serai pas les français
puis l'histoire du français lizotte du
poids de français et de la francophonie
le côté anglophone la ville est la
séparation tout seul je le connaissais
pas à l'extérieur on voit pas ces gens
chaud et qu'est ce que vous voyez vous
voyez la ville comme tel c'était vous
voir c'est la ville et montréal c'est
extraordinaire comme québec en fait et
attire beaucoup plus québec parce que
ces villes de l'unesco comme alors
mémorial c'est le deuxième incident
chute à nouveau de ce côté là du canada
c'est québec qui montréal d'accord mais
ce ne sont pas deux destinations
touristiques mais là aussi on tend plus
au sens large de 2 m 2 de ville
le mega ois et de mégapoles moi je suis
passé par toronto la semaine dernière
une en vacances je m'attendais pas à me
retrouver là mais à chaque fois que je
vais à toronto
d'abord je déteste le pourri je peux
vous avez norauto fou c'est quelque
chose mais au plan de ses comme une
ville asiatique maintenant temps avec
les tours d'habitation les bureaux c'est
extrêmement c'est incroyable il ya 16
voies de circulation sur plusieurs
kilomètres qui traverse toute la ville
quand je dis c'est je suis encore au
modèle je pense qu'elle n'a plus que ça
c'est incroyable cette ville si on parle
de grandeur de grandeur en fait c'est
que j'ai compris toujours de toronto
c'est toronto
c'est la plus américaine des villes
canadien en fait c'est comme si tu te
promènes à bostens de la shoah c'est
beaucoup plus que postaux louis ghost on
sait morial snes et des villes de paca
moyenne grandeur au niveau de
l'architecturé au niveau des ponts ce
sont les mêmes architectes qui ont
construit des ponts de new york de
baston montréal
la ville de québec cessé les mêmes
écoles c'est les mêmes c'est les mêmes
ingénieurs mais toronto c'est vous dites
la plus américaine je pense que c'est
peut-être là plusieurs sciatique
maintenant débloquer ou de l'
architecture parce que moi je suis
impressionné par ses textures - par
parler c'est un marché que sont pas à
paris ou cdd quartiers ont-ils qui sont
ni même époque nous il ya quand même un
souci d'urbanisme pour que tout soit
bien homogène de l'urbanisme
ok alors on finira pas de débat là non
il ne fait que lancer
et puis merci beaucoup d'avoir participé
en si petit nombre à ce grand
anniversaire données de montréal la
semaine prochaine je vous laisse deviner
le thème de l'émission c'est pas un jeu
questionnaire dont capa 250e du canada
non ce serait trop comme trop tôt ouais
les climats le clignement 24 juin
peut-être oui - la saint-jean-baptiste
mis la puce à l'oreille je suis là pour
aider moi je facilitateur un peu comme
on a beaucoup échoué en alumine
l'émission c'est bon qu'à la fin de nous
donne des petits j'étais un cancre à
l'école donc je sais comme [ __ ]
comment aider ceux qui veulent m
secourus mais fantastique merci beaucoup
merci à toi leonardo gimeno et puis
marie claude simard aux cheveux courts
la semaine prochaine sa maman